[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
alors mon bébé questerre a mené alors
qu'est-ce que j'en ai enfin de
chroniques on va revenir sur le plus
gros clash de l'histoire je pense de ces
huit le plus gros clash des soirs de
suite vous verrez parce que ce week-end
c'est évident balances ton post et ce
avec cyril lambrot son poste vous avez
réussi à devenir ce mélange si
particulier entre jean pierre elkabbach
et arlette chabot la différence ou des
83 ans de moins et ça y est pas mal mais
je dis je me suis rendu compte que vous
animez les débats comme un des
animateurs préférés à l'époque vous
répétiez sans arrêt souplesse ou plus à
souplesse yoplait ça vous dit quelque
chose doit donc ce tic fait que bâle on
se trompe on devrait plutôt s'appeler
ciel mon jeudi
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
ça va pas trouver mais si ça vous plaît
c'est vrai tu me charrient en faisant ça
on sait bien parce que je dis c'est
souper chez nous c'est ta gueule on va
justement qsi jeudi soir vous avez une
qualité principale justement c'est que
vous êtes patient vraiment vous est de
plus passé en du monde la france vous
restez zen en toute situation
même quand vos chroniqueurs vous invitez
[ __ ] le dawa je n'avais pas vous
restez jamais le temps c'est incroyable
ça mais bon un petit peu quand même avec
raquel garrido
franchement elle avait décidé de battre
le record du nombre de mots dits en une
émission je pense votre flames vraiment
est à montrer dans toutes les écoles de
journalisme politique
regardez la maîtrise de la force avec
métro baby sitting coupe
votre technique et de chanter pour vous
détendre ça marche bien parce qu'avec
raquel garrido vous restait encore très
patient franchement bravo
[Musique]
sauter la tête et noir sur twitter est
ce qu'on peut demander à la régie de
couper le micro de raquel s'il vous
plaît oui à m'arrêter
donc arretez rester calme tu devras
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
38 et bébé en vrai naulleau va eric
pardon a été très bon face à laquelle je
trouvais très très bon ah oui la petite
joute verbale là tu l'as cannes gentil
raquel ce qui s'embrouillent dans
l'émission pays
bah oui ce serait oui mais je laime vous
posez mais sa petite joute verbale qui
s'annonce aussi ben voilà c'est ça qu'on
veut oui mais justement depuis qu'eric
naulleau est avec nous c'est vrai que
vous avez découvert qu'ils savent s
exprimer sans dire un mot avec sa tête
elle parle peu jeudi il était assis à
côté justement de raquel garrido [ __ ]
alors oui mais voilà fin prêts à boucher
un vegan c'est pareil entre eux c'est
encore pire même c'est à dire que je
pense que si on vous demande d'eric si
vous préférez passer trente secondes et
raquel ou lire qui faisont série après
quoi changer jt alors à chaque fois
aurait valu le bouquin lebouc à
l'origine airbus il a lui même fait
riche et badauds et moi faisons un
best-seller à ouarzazate il paraît alors
à chaque fois à chaque fois craqué elle
prend la parole éric et soul et parce
qu'elle dit mais comment plus elle le
dit très fort il a encore plus ou les
îles acheteur pour son tympan vous allez
voir c'est le retourner à tata nano
ils sont représentés la voilà voilà
je pensais pas me faire valider un jour
pas mal ainsi que sa réponse
et pas un argent s'il te plaît on va
voir les émeutes
[Musique]
mais l'effort de mélenchon ça n'est
jamais tout en haut
mr des séries comme vous appel à l'aide
pour abréger ses souffrances il y avait
non pas une guerre l'aitf outre les
riches est arrêté
[Musique]
lui
il ya d'autres choses à bien sûr alors
je dis vous recevez donc jean bastide
djebbari qui étaient acides qui étaient
là debout avec vous sa secrétaire d'état
chargé des transports ça calme je peux
ça veut dire mais ça calme il a répondu
à toutes les questions pendant sept
heures et je pense l'avoir qui répondent
à une ère série qui a déjà été contacté
pour la prochaine saison de masse singer
regardez d'habitude quand on bâtit
jebbari va sur un plateau télé y débat
avec des personnes comme cette
journaliste caroline roux le retrait de
la réforme
est ce que c'est une option coiffure à
prêter maquillage léger tenues strictes
alors que quand il vient d'en bas lance
ton post le look des intervenants il est
différent
manu qu'est-ce qu'il avait demandé alors
voix de dark vador masque de chat les
lunettes de soleil de maître gims et une
perruque
d'ailleurs on ne la fait pas je sais qui
a déjà porté cette perruque parce que la
policière a donné un indice
comment voulez vous balancer des
grenades sans savoir où cette série
regardez qui portait cette même perruque
à quelques semaines dans tpm p
[Applaudissements]
il peut acheter notre mail été formé à
cette policière était fier d'elle alors
j'ai encore un extrait bien sûr
extraordinaire de balances ton post à
vous montrer j'en ai parlé où vous allez
voir le plus gros clash de l'histoire de
ces 8 mai avant la baston j'ai envie
d'un peu d'amour parmi la dame a bien
sûr on adore ça parce que dans la grande
marque à samedi magloire a eu un coup de
coeur
ah ouais ça vous allez voir c'est sûr
qu'il va pechos1 j'espère pour lui c'est
le premier épisode d'amour ma gloire et
beauté
la loi vous savez ce qui vient de me
confier il avait un crush pour quelqu'un
qui est dans le public ici et qu'ils ne
savaient pas c'est pour finir l'émission
parce que ses bras c'est des mensonges
et des bras des ment on est sûr que ce
n'est pas fabien lecoeuvre
car ce qui est vraiment chez lui et dans
son slip il s'agit en fait d'un agent de
sécurité
j'ai une bonne nouvelle je vous libère
pour tpm et bien oui quand l'amour
frappe à la porte
cyril hanouna ne pense plus aux
professionnels le souci c'est que tout
le monde rigole sauf patrick
[Applaudissements]
sagen ne va faire qu'empirer car
désormais magloire n'a plus qu'un mot à
la bouche décrit un chroniqueur ne sent
pas bien
eh bien oui mais je vote en mai par
patrick est pris d'un malaise
malheureusement pour lui le seul qui a
son diplôme de secouriste c'est fabien
lecoeuvre
contre toute attente patrick semble
jaloux
sauf que vendredi magloire il semble
avoir été charmé par premier le coeur le
séducteur aux petits corps
moi j'ai fait courir encore plus mal
après quoi
voilà alors c'est vrai qu'il est beau
des jambes et en pied également sur sa
patrie superbe à l'orangé nos missions
normales les clash se font entre
intervenants et chroniqueur alors pas de
violence ton post est la particularité
de voir des clashs directement entre
chroniqueurs bon ça qui est bien jimmy
mohamed contre eric naulleau quand deux
intellectuels s'insultent au csa ils
sont déçus parce qu'ils savent très bien
qu'ils se rend pas trois millions qu'a
eu le clash boubakary c'est bien encore
moins fort le clash naulleau mohamed
regarder mais n'est peut-être gêné des
intervenants ça fait pas fait gaffe
latendresse a même c'est vrai c'est vrai
c'est comme quand tu invites un week-end
chez un couple d'amis s'embrouille c'est
pour rien et moi ça donc ce qu'on aime
c'est signé mohamed
c'est cette fois de vive il regrette
d'avoir accepté de faire une coloscopie
à jean-michel alors qu'il commence à
fatiguer puisque l'émission a commencé
jeudi qu'on est déjà dimanche la
nouvelle de naulleau sur garrido va le
réveiller
une question est ce que la pénibilité
inclut des acouphènes d'abord
m'intéresse beaucoup comme ça y est le
docteur mois mais vu comment sa
transformation en david banner alors
conséquent produits il suffira d'une
étincelle pour allumer le feu
le polémiste va lui donner un surnom qui
va réveiller définitivement et jimmy et
moi même temps minimal et fini sa phrase
qu'elle veut bien me laisser là fini
6 min cricket croyable
marca c'est toi vous êtes en train de
tracer des baleines franches moi vous
dire à ses rivaux directs le cadre est
comparé des données réelles du type clp
[Applaudissements]
c'est pas une insulte mais voilà
maintenant parce qu'on a l'impression
qu'on est des quilles qui les bat on a
insulté sa mère
j'élabore 6 mai prochain il serait passé
les admire c'est pas une insulte à la
peinture et oui et maintenant on le
prend avec le sourire on a fait une dame
mais oui c'est pour réveiller en moi
mais mon moment préféré aux mots qu'il a
pris bravo ou cédric parce que c'est
quand est ce que moi j'ai vu que j'étais
l'alcool jiminy cricket
[Applaudissements]